♪ ♪
>> Gregg: WELCOME BACK TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY,"
TRUMP VERSUS THE RESISTANCE.
WITH THE FOURTH OF JULY RIGHT
AROUND THE CORNER OF A FEW HOURS
FROM NOW, ONE OF THE BIGGEST
SOCIAL JUSTICE WARRIORS IN THE
COUNTRY IS SHOWING HIS
PATRIOTISM BY CALLING THE
AMERICAN FLAG RACIST.
THAT'S RIGHT, EX-NFL QUARTERBACK
COLIN KAEPERNICK TOLD NIKE THAT
IT SHOE FEATURING THE ICONIC
BETSY ROSS FLAG WAS OFFENSIVE
BECAUSE 250 YEARS AGO SOME
AMERICANS OWNED SLAVES.
NIKE SUBSEQUENTLY PULLED THE
SHOE FROM ITS STORE SHELVES.
THIS IS THE SAME BETSY ROSS FLAG
PROMINENTLY DISPLAYED AT
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S SECOND
INAUGURAL.
THERE WAS NO OUTRAGE THEN.
I DID NOT HEAR FROM
COLIN KAEPERNICK.
BUT NATURALLY MANY IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA ARE BACKING
NIKE'S DECISION,
COLIN KAEPERNICK'S FAUX MORAL
OUTRAGE NOTWITHSTANDING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS REPUBLICAN RP
>> THIS REPUBLICAN RB
>> THIS REPUBLICAN RI
>> THIS REPUBLICAN RA
>> THIS REPUBLICAN RN
>> THIS REPUBLICAN RI
>> THIS REPUBLICAN RT
>> THIS REPUBLICAN RE
>> THIS REPUBLICAN RF
>> THIS REPUBLICAN RU
>> THIS REPUBLICAN RX
OUTRAGE IS ALMOST LAUGHABLE.
THE SHOE, THE FLAG IT, IT
REPRESENTED A PERIOD OF TIME
WHERE WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, I
WAS THREE FIFTHS OF A HUMAN
BEING.
THAT IS AN ISSUE.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO GO TO THE
TIME.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE EARLY
VERSION OF THE AMERICAN FLAG,
WHAT DOES IT SYMBOLIZE?
>> IT SYMBOLIZES, I SEE THE
COLONIES AND THAT LEADS DIRECTLY
TO SLAVERY.
>> IN SOME CASES THE BETSY ROSS
FLAG HAS BEEN CO-OPTED BY WHITE
SUPREMACIST GROUPS LIKE THE KKK.
>> NOW THE FLAG HAS BEEN USED BY
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO PUMMEL
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,, AND OTHER
PEOPLE, NEO-NAZIS WHO WANT TO
CLAIM THAT THEY HAVE THE TRUE
COPYRIGHT ON AMERICAN IDENTITY,
WHY NOT CHOOSE A FLAG THAT IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF ANY NOMADIC
EVERYBODY?
>> Gregg: IT IS NOT JUST THE
MEDIA, SEVERAL 2020 DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES ALSO WEIGHING IN AND
TRASHING THE AMERICAN FLAG.
JOINING ABOUT IT, SAIL NATIONAL
RADIO SYNDICATED HOST AND TO
CINDY LOU.
I GUESS THAT COLIN KAEPERNICK
RUNS NIKES THESE DAYS, WHAT IS
NEXT, RED, WHITE, AND BLUE
SNEAKERS WILL BE BANNED?
NO, WHITE SNEAKERS, BECAUSE THAT
IS WHITE SUPREMACIST.
>> WHO KNEW THAT
COLIN KAEPERNICK HAD THIS POWER?
MY GOODNESS, HE WAS ABLE TO GET
NIKE TO RECALL ISSUE THAT THEY
HAD ALREADY MANUFACTURED ALL
BECAUSE HE COMPLAINED, WHAT
WOULD'VE HAPPENED HAD
COLIN KAEPERNICK NOT COMPLAINED
AND THE SHOE HAD COME OUT?
NOBODY WOULD'VE CARED.
SO THIS WAS ALL
COLIN KAEPERNICK'S CALL.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
HE DOES NOT HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THE FLAG AS HE POINTED OUT.
OBAMA HAD NOT WON, BUT TWO BIG
BETSY ROSS FLAG SAID HIS SECOND
INAUGURAL AND THE CURRENT FLAG
THAT WE HAVE HAD SINCE 1960 HAS
13 STRIPES ON IT, ONE OF WHICH
FOR THE ORIGINAL 13 COLONISTS
AND 50 STARS, 13 OF WHICH ARE
REPRESENTING THE ORIGINAL 13
COLONIES.
SO COLIN KAEPERNICK HAS A
PROBLEM NOT WITH THE BETSY ROSS
FLAG, BUT FLAGS IN GENERAL,
DON'T GO TO A
PHILADELPHIA-76ers GAME,
BECAUSE THAT SAME BETSY ROSS
INSIGNIA IS THERE LOGO.
>> Gregg: YOU KNOW, KATHY,
COME ON.
I'M CONFUSED, NEVER OCCURRED TO
ME THAT THE, I THOUGHT 13
COLONIES WAS REPRESENTED BY THE
BETSY ROSS FLAG, SINCE WHEN IS A
REALLY MEANINGFUL AS WHITE
SUPREMACY SYMBOLS?
>> SINCE COLIN KAEPERNICK
BROUGHT IT UP, AND IT HAS CAUSED
SO MANY PEOPLE --
>> Gregg: SO HE IS THE FINAL
ARBITER WITH MORAL SUPREMACY?
>> NOT THE FINAL, NO, NOT THE
FINAL AT ALL.
TO THE BEGINNING.
HE IS STARTING THE CONVERSATION.
NO, NIKE HAS MADE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WITH THE PARTNERSHIP
WITH COLIN KAEPERNICK.
HE IS A SOCIAL JUSTICE WARRIOR,
PART OF A COUNTERCULTURE
MOVEMENT IN THIS COUNTRY THAT IS
SO AMERICAN AND PATRIOTIC TO
QUESTION EVERYTHING.
DON'T JUST BELIEVE EVERYTHING.
>> Gregg: WHY ISN'T
COLIN KAEPERNICK CONCERNED ABOUT
NIKE MOVING A LOT OF THEIR
PRODUCTION JOBS TO CHINA, WHICH
IS ONE OF THE WORLD'S BIGGEST
DIFFUSERS OF HUMAN RIGHTS
INCLUDING IMPRISONMENT AND
TORTURE AND EXECUTION OF PEOPLE
WHO DARE TO DISAGREE WITH THE
GOVERNMENT, BUT I'M NOT HEARING
HIM GET UPSET ABOUT THAT.
>> ONE ISSUE AT A TIME, AND
ARIZONA IS TAKING OUT A FACTORY
AND ARIZONA IS SAYING BRING IT
OVER TO US, AND WE SHOULD BE
UPSET WITH ARIZONA, THEY ARE
TAKING AWAY 500 JOBS.
CALIFORNIA SAID BRING THEM TO
US.
SO CALIFORNIA IS ACTUALLY
COMPLAINING ABOUT CHINA TAKING
THE JOBS.
SO GOOD FOR COLIN KAEPERNICK TO
MAKE A POINT THAT CALIFORNIA
WANTS TO BRING THEM BACK TO AMEI
WANTS TO BRING THEM BACK TO AMEA
WANTS TO BRING THEM BACK TO AME.
SO THE CONVERSATION IS THEY ARE.
>> Gregg: LARRY, I WILL LEAD
IT TO YOU TO CORRECT KATHY ON
THIS ISSUE.
>> WELL, SHE SAID ONE ISSUE AT A
TIME, OF ALL OF THE ISSUES
FACING THE COUNTRY AND BLACK
AMERICANS IN PARTICULAR, THE
BETSY ROSS SHOE DOES NOT EVEN
MAKE THE CUT.
IF COLIN KAEPERNICK HAS THIS
POWER AND PERSUASIVENESS AND
CLOUT ON SOCIAL MEDIA, HOW ABOUT
DEALING WITH THE NUMBER ONE
PROBLEM FACING BLACK AMERICA AND
THAT IS THE LACK OF FATHERS IN
THE HOME.
HOW ABOUT DEALING WITH THE POOR
GOVERNMENT SCHOOLS THAT KIDS GO
TO?
OR THE DROPOUT RATE IN SOME
INNER'S CITY SCHOOLS APPROACHING
50%, HOW ABOUT DEALING WITH SOME
OF THESE TRIVIAL PROBLEMS NOW
THAT WE HAVE MATTERED THE BETSY
ROSS PROBLEM?
>> Gregg: BETSY ROSS WAS A
REMARKABLE WOMAN WHO HAD HER OWN
BUSINESS AND SHE SEWED TO THE
FLAG AND CREATED THE FLAG, I
THINK THAT YOU WOULD BE STICKING
UP FOR HER?
>> YES, AND I AM SO HAPPY THAT
COLIN KAEPERNICK BROUGHT UP THE
ISSUE THAT BETSY ROSS MADE THIS
FLAG AND COULD NOT EVEN VOTE AT
THE TIME THAT SHE ACTUALLY MADE
THE FLAG.